proboscis monkeys is an endemic species
in Borneo in Indonesia we call them the
Canton once in the water proboscis
monkeys swim with power pole and
confident dog pedal but they can also
dive and propel themselves for distance
beneath the surface in finger and toes a
partially webbed that's why they can
swim and die the factor that caused the
Canton swim is a predator attack some of
the predator like large lizard crocodile
and some upward that handled a baby like
eagle so they always looking for the
escape and the other factor when the
limited availability of food in their
habitat they will cross the river to
area to another area to looking for the
hood and have a predicate great swimmer
they have a big alumnos for mal but
female noses are not as large like mal
but larger than most monkeys besides
that they happen nasal fell under news
their habitats are in the mixed dr.
Cochran's forest magnet Horace a lowland
forest with fresh water and river they
are categorized endangered species by
ucn an appendix one by sight
if you do not conserve and protect them
we will lose the Primus word must
fulfill a swimmer
[Music]